it looks like more people are waiting
longer for rides on rtc buses data shows
ridership on the strip is on the rise
but overall productivity and on-time
performance is down around the rest of
the city jeremy j ford is live in the
newsroom tonight with more jeremy
well according to rtc's website
rideshare outside of the strip is down
29 from before the pandemic this is due
in part to driver shortage
on time performance is also at its
lowest since before the pandemic this
afternoon i spoke with commuter
edith garcia who says she believes some
people are choosing not to take public
transportation because of inconsistent
bus times but she says she hasn't had a
problem there's very few times where
they've been
laid but mostly they are on time and i
really only use the buses in the morning
from seven o'clock
till mostly like five six so i don't
know how it is after hours you know but
yes they say that after 10 o'clock
sometimes
the buses are late because of the charge
of drivers
well recently many rtc routes have been
changed or cut due to driver shortage
and on rtc's website they say quote
scheduled times are approximate and may
vary due to unusual traffic conditions
or other significant disruptions along
the route they also ask commuters to
plan accordingly from the newsroom
jeremy j ford is live and local now